do you keep copies of your screenplays
in your car I do I keep them keep them
gosh I've got I keep two in my bag and
you know I just believe in fact I gave
one to someone I met in the hall we were
talking and the guy is your calling card
you know of course i was i'm not gonna
walk around on the hall pass and not to
everyone but if I feel like the
conversation warrants it I gave it to
this person because he's a struggling
writer and he said to me man i just
don't know you know what to do I pitch
it and they don't get me in whatever and
so I gave it to him and I showed him
seven versions is what it took to get to
this point so he left I think but uh I
just gave it to us a man it takes you
awhile you can't quit you know because
really you know you come to these pitch
fest and you're overwhelmed especially
if you've never been to one one guy in
the bathroom I told him he was so
nervous I said man look you know and I
don't know why me everybody's asking me
you know but up but I don't care i'll
tell him i said you know man look this
guy put him his pants the way you did
this morning probably you know I don't
think his pants just appeared on him
happy so he he does the same thing you
do every day probably he's a human being
and so calm down he's about throw up I
know that's vulgar but that's he was
everybody kept walking past them I said
you all right man you know he's ready
you know and so he calmed down and later
on I what the lodge came back at he's in
the hall it's a guy man thanks you saved
me you know i mean you know i'll save
you and nothing like it but i just want
you to know that these are people in
that room you know and they've got
something you need that you've got
something they need they need you more
than you need them and that's why I keep
coming to Hollywood because think about
it I mean if they don't have stories how
Hollywood doesn't exist that's the way I
keep myself going anyway
you